well mr speaker i thank the secretary of
state for advanced site
of her statement and for the continued
briefing that she continues to give me
on privy council terms
we have all been inspired by the gallant
and tenacious actions of ukrainians in
defense of their country
this is true courage under fire
president zielenski has epitomized the
bravery the dignity and resolve of a
nation
fighting back
fighting for values that we all share
for democracy
for freedom and for the rule of law
the foreign secretary is right when she
says that putin's invasion is not so far
going to plan
but will she agree with me
that we must not let our focus slip for
even a second
we will continue to stand united with
our allies and partners supporting
ukraine and opposing this outrageous
campaign of aggression
mr speaker this morning i had the honor
of meeting with ukraine's ambassador
with the shadow defense secretary
he thanked all sides of this house for
the united opposition that we have shown
to vladimir putin's illegal war
and the support we continue to show for
ukrainian sovereignty
putin is not only facing a united west
he is facing a truly united kingdom
together we have enacted sanctions that
are having a strong effect
the ruble has crashed by over 40 percent
the main borrowing rate is up 20
and inflation is reportedly hitting
around 65 percent per year
oligarchs are being frozen out
of their bank accounts and the central
bank of russia is being blocked from
part of the 640 billion war chest that
it holds in foreign reserves
labour's priority is to cut off putin's
rogue state from our economic system and
to undermine his campaign of aggression
in ukraine
mr speaker we recognize that on the 24th
of february
the european security order changed
our continent faces a transformed
strategic context our world is at the
start of a new era
i pay tribute to the political courage
shown by all of our partners
particularly our allies in germany
who have recognized that by taking the
difficult and brave decisions to provide
ukraine with lethal weapons for its
fight and to commit to the significant
increases in defense spending that this
new reality demands
yesterday president putin raised the
alert level of russian nuclear forces
mr speaker
as the five nuclear weapons states
including russia
reaffirmed in january a nuclear war
cannot be won and must never be fought
can i ask for her assessment of this
decision
given the understandable concern it will
have caused amongst the public
turning to sanctions we welcome the
further steps the government has
announced today
the progress made by the uk the eu and
the u.s on cutting off russian banks
from swift
it's something labour has called for for
some time the moves to finally clamp
down on dirty money so long demanded by
labour and colleagues across the house
are long overdue it's regrettable that
it's taken this long and a crisis of
this nature for action
but we welcome the steps and we'll study
them carefully
but there's still more the government
can do
the last time i stood at this dispatch
bot i asked what steps the government
has taken to ensure members of russia's
legislature the duma can be sanctioned
still today i'm waiting for that answer
similarly while i welcome the foreign
secretary's action against russia's
financial sector the government should
go further to ensure sanctions can be
placed against russia's extractive
industries energy industries and
technological industries and we believe
that we must ensure that the insurance
industry cannot underwrite and de-risk
putin's war
as i said during last that my last time
at the dispatch box it's vital that
these sanctions are broad enough to
inflict damage on every aspect of
russia's economy
we welcome the moves that the government
have taken to ensure russia is cut out
of the swift banking system but can the
foreign secretary explain the dialogue
that she's had with our allies about
cutting the country out of the visa
mastercard system too
finally can the foreign secretary give
assurances that putin will also feel the
consequences of his despicable actions
in terms of international opportunities
available to the country in sports and
culture
the diplomatic unity of the west is
crucial that we must also widen the
global coalition opposing the war
i pay tribute to the political courage
shown by our partners particularly our
allies germany
who recognize this
but
difficult and brave decisions
also require further action
some countries like kenya have spoken
out with clarity and elegance about
putin's imperialism
but others have stayed silent some are
even allies of the uk and fellow
democracies so can i ask what steps the
foreign secretary is taking to ensure
that the widest policy possible range of
voices
speaks up in opposition to this war mr
speaker as well as commending the
bravery of ukrainians demanding their
country we must also praise the courage
of ordinary russians taken to the
streets of moscow in saint petersburg
and beyond under the threat of
regression to show their opposition to
this despot mr speaker this is the fifth
day of fighting ukraine is still facing
uh an all-out war from putin's army it's
a mark of the bravery of ukraine's
forces that neither kiev nor kharkiv
have fallen
we salute their courage and this whole
house will continue to stand with